thank you
hey what's going on I pushed the button
at all I saw was the back of your head
yeah
it's already becoming the poop show yeah
yeah well you didn't turn the fan oh
she's gonna wait for it to go on she's
like I know you're gonna turn the fan on
and I'm gonna get really upset about it
look she's looking yeah that's it
it's gonna start yelling
she's got to say something about it
you turned it on yeah okay hold on
hold on yeah what are you doing yeah
she's happening
murder Hornet said train intro I didn't
play the train intro did I I didn't
change no I don't think so I mean I
don't think I did because that's way
down there near the bottom I should have
played with another day intro because
we're talking about a movie because it's
Tuesday I think it's Tuesday right yep I
don't know this is we uh we're doing we
did platoon symptoms
yeah Louie sent us that was movie this
one movie two yeah
so we did Tombstone did uh platoon yeah
platoon's a good movie it is uh we it
was popular in the Army when I was in
the Army for those who don't know me I
served at that time I was serving the
first and the five or six up in Korea
and that movie had come out already and
we were watching it
all right it's an infantry Air Assault
infantry unit and uh we liked all those
Vietnam movies we still had Squad
leaders
um platoon sergeants and first sergeants
from the Vietnam conflict my first
sergeant was famous for Vietnam he
served two tours there went up and down
Hamburger Hill three times
and his platoon took like 70 80
casualties they almost all got wiped out
thanks yeah we I asked him about it one
time and it says I heard you went up and
down Hamburger Hill he goes what
happened down here we go three times and
he pulled it in his wallet and came and
he came up with a bunch of pictures of
all his dead buddies out on the flight
line because he took pictures of him
before the helicopters took him away it
was [ __ ]
he says I carry him Wherever I Go
yeah I get that yeah and they really he
was one of the guys he was a lifer they
couldn't let him out really they just
kept promoting him and keeping him in
the military
he just he went through so much [ __ ]
man [ __ ]
so many of his friends died he he'd
never make a good civilians he just
stayed in
but uh that was uh
[ __ ] no I want to say his name is
Hendricks but his name was not Hendrix
I'm [ __ ] drawing a blank now
um we just called him hard rock that was
his [ __ ] RV name yeah first hard
um anyway
um
it's a good movie
in some ways it's real true to life to
infantry culture
it's kind of true to the era in which
the story's being told but there are
also a lot of inaccuracies to it well
which I'll get to it or you know over
time there's a lot of Hollywood in in
any kind of War movie you know well the
thing about I kind of feel like this has
less than
uh normal I suppose I mean because
Oliver Stone I mean famously this was
the first Vietnam movie that was made by
an actual Vietnam veteran because Oliver
Stone if you didn't know like did a tour
in Vietnam and he actually based um he
had actually like written a screenplay
back in 1968 which was called Break like
as soon as he got home from Vietnam and
he started writing about his experiences
and eventually like over many years that
would end up becoming platoon and so
he's writing about his own experiences
most of the characters in this were
based on people that he knew or um you
know amalgamations of people that he
knew like during the thing he was
basically like the Charlie Sheen
character you know what I mean he was
because like the Charlie Sheen character
in this movie Oliver Stone also
volunteered uh for infantry he
volunteered to go into Vietnam he was
not drafted so you know just like
Charlie Sheen's character so he's kind
of like meant to be the audience
surrogate like the every man type
character and like and then it's almost
kind of like he's the audience where
he's seeing this kind of like morality
play like playing out like between the
two sergeants you know what I mean like
uh Barnes and Elias who were like two
sides of same coin type thing I'll just
get the inaccuracies out of way and then
we'll get into we'll get into the movie
first inaccuracy is that the guns are
incorrect the squad leaders are carrying
the Colt Model 600 series price 635
series which was an export model to
Philippines 14.5 inch barrel with an A2
style flash suppressor it had a forward
assist on it I even think it had a case
deflector
which that was that was nowhere near
Vietnam that was much much later I think
they're trying to [ __ ] show an xm177
or you know the early car 15 is what
it's supposed to be but that's a law
enforcement car being for an export
bottle that never served in Vietnam
um
the AKA when there was a norenco type 56
they showed a lot of those which that
was contemporary for the 80s and the 90s
I'm not quite sure the type 56 was in
Vietnam they've broken because there was
a lot of different iterations and I
think most of the Vietnam's AKs were
milled receiver AKs
which is for you gun experts you know
what I'm talking about
um other than that I was an M60 Gunner
and they're [ __ ] the way they showed
the m60s as spot on even got the sound
correct uh some of the stuff that they
got wrong is that the belts were all
down in the mud in a [ __ ] they're
still [ __ ] fire those things that jam
up [ __ ] as soon as there is anything
on those [ __ ] linked ammunition you
pull it into the [ __ ] tree feed tray
on the top of the gut it [ __ ] jam it
they weren't that reliable uh didn't
like that machine gun they eventually
replaced it
it took an expert to keep that [ __ ]
running
um which they all drilled that into us
another thing that was inaccurate is
that they're not very rarely wearing
headgear and they have long hair you had
guys with long hair in in the Vietnam
theater at certain years usually that
was earlier on
in the conflict and it was special
forces guys that had long hair and they
would put them in hokey camouflage
outfits and give them random weapons
from around the world and their cover
story was is that they were
International mercenaries so that's why
they had long hair they were trying to
disguise themselves as something other
than US Army
um I've seen some videos later on where
some of the guys kind of have longish
hair but
man Vietnam is [ __ ] hot and wet
anybody worth their Salt's gonna [ __ ]
have real short hair or no hair because
it's [ __ ] miserable uh doing what
they were doing they were mostly doing
patrols patrols at a fire bases
uh and they wore headgear uh
served with a lot of Vietnam vets and
they would kind of say yeah they're
always showing them it's like rag bags
and [ __ ]
when when there's time to take photos a
lot of times you're not you're not in
combat you're not fighting when
photographs are being taken so their
helmets are off they might even have
flat vests off even equipment's off and
they're taking pictures of each other
because they're resting they're in a
safe area when they're working and
fighting they you they had [ __ ] steel
pot helmets on flag vests they were
wearing a lot of stuff so they they
actually ran a pretty tight ship you
couldn't just make [ __ ] up you know I
mean just wear whatever you wanted to
wear
now maybe early on but uh everything I
heard from guys that were there said
that they actually ran a pretty
disciplined a pretty tight ship it was
very conventional
so uh but they did do drugs they did do
[ __ ] they did crazy [ __ ] every now and
then because it was a very confusing
environment they weren't sure what the
rules of engagement were they didn't
really even know who they were fighting
uh it was more like a law enforcement
thing
and if somebody ran they thought they
were enemy uh if somebody wore black
pajamas they might be enemy but
everybody's wearing black pajamas it was
just
it took about a year to figure out what
was going on there and they were only
there for a year rotation so by the time
they've the individual Soldier figured
out what the [ __ ] was going on it was
time for him to leave
it was a [ __ ] never should have
[ __ ] been well yeah I mean
it was just Ron from from it was run
from back in the Pentagon in Washington
DC by guys that didn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on and they're just doing
things by the numbers and it was uh
which is not a good way to do it and and
they thought that if they just killed
enough people that the war would be over
and that's not the way War Works uh you
have to achieve some kind of a goal and
they didn't have a goal to achieve
I think it was mostly just about making
contract money and testing out weapons
it's probably what it was more about
they didn't really care about Vietnam
per se
what a cluster what I was going to say
about
um you know everybody being like what
you were saying earlier about the you
know people wearing what they want or
the headgear or whatever I kind of feel
like that's kind of an acceptable you
know fudge like in movies because a lot
of times like you want to be able to
like distinguish all the characters from
one another you have to look different
so you want to be able to see their
faces and like they have to have like
slightly different hairs so they're not
kind of all yeah because you know if
they shaved all their heads were all
wearing helmets you'd be like well who
the [ __ ] was that now you know what I
mean it's a movie so you have to do give
it like some but you know for like from
what I said like it does seem like
um a lot of guys that were in Vietnam
like really do relate to this movie
because it like brings back a lot of
memories for them I was like um I was
reading like uh I've watched like a few
videos about this it was actually a
really good one uh this one channel that
does analyzing evil and always does kind
of like villains from all the movies and
like does these really in-depth kind of
things and they're really good
um but he did one about Barnes and I was
reading some of the um comments under
that and some of the people were like
older guys that had been in Vietnam and
you know they either said yeah I really
love this movie because it was you know
kind of like my experience but a couple
of the people were like well I kind of
don't want to watch it because like
because I've heard that it's like
realistic and it'll remind me so there's
that as well Vietnam vets that I served
with this is back in their very early
90s early to mid 90s
um
we pretty we watched them all and
according to those guys and we kind of
went along with it the most accurate one
that I remembered was Hamburger Hill
which I haven't seen in years yeah
Hamburger Hill
every Vietnam veteran was like no that's
that it was like that that that's what
it was and the way they were doing [ __ ]
was basically the exact same way we were
doing things in the 90s it was just like
that it was just a different theater
um but over time
because of film reels and [ __ ] and how
it got filtered down into the American
psyche during the 60s and the 70s what
you have is is portrayals of Vietnam
more like platoon and Apocalypse Now
which those are great movies although
apocalypse now I kind of feel like is a
lot more
dreamlikeology whereas this one is a lot
more grounded in reality it's not really
um it's not all that overblown at all
it's not really it you can tell that
like Oliver Stone is trying to keep it
like is kind of ground and unrealistic
as possible I remember thinking you know
that we were all blown away by Hamburger
Hill and these are guys that some of the
guys that were watching it with us were
Vietnam veterans they said no that's
what it was like
so I want to see that one again too yeah
I remember that being really good but
like I said I when did that come out
early 90s early 90s I think what was it
93 how do I remember that I don't know
and unless that's wrong there's another
one that kind of had an All-Star cast it
was another good movie it's just that
that one was not quite as flashy and
it's kind of big it was slightly lower
budget I think yeah although this one I
was shocked when I looked up platoon
um I believe it cost six and a half
million to make that's it
um they shot it in the Philippines like
they usually do with uh with movies
about Vietnam that's where they got
those that's where they got those Cults
well that's what I was gonna say earlier
like what I said that's probably why
because they shot it Philippines yeah
but um you know because like I said
that's a Filipino right contract weapon
but I mean this movie was I remember
this came out this was 1986 and um I
mean this was massively successful it
did what it made like 140 million or
something like that it might have been
it was a massive hit uh it won best
picture that year uh Oliver Stone won
best director that year I think it won a
couple more Oscars and it was nominated
for eight I kind of like Willem Dafoe
was nominated uh I think Tom Behringer
was nominated they didn't win but they
were all nominated and I had forgotten
because like I said it's been I've seen
this movie a couple of times but it's
probably been it's 20 years since I've
seen it I remembered Willem Dafoe in it
I remembered Tom Beringer in it I
remember Charlie Sheen in it but I
forgot that Keith David is in this yeah
I forgot that Kevin Dillon was in this
yeah I forgot that uh Johnny Depp Johnny
Depp was in this like very very young
Forest Whitaker is in this Tony Todd is
in this
um like it's a very small part but it's
like I was like man this is another
movie where I'm like am I doing this
all-star cast I was 14 years old when
this movie came up maybe I'm in there
I'm not really sure but yeah like
everybody like it had a massive massive
uh cast again like just like we were
talking about with Tombstone like just
had a [ __ ] stacked cast and he was
there are so many good actors in it that
like you forget like all these other
great actors that rented as well because
they were just kind of like it was just
such a good Ensemble piece but I mean
the thing about I kind of feel like I I
kind of feel like either Tom Behringer
or Willem Dafoe should have won maybe I
think they were both nominated for um
for a Best Supporting Actor but they
were both great in this because like I
said Charlie Sheen I mean he's Charlie
Sheen you know what I mean he's kind of
like like I said he's the audience
surrogate he was kind of like the Oliver
Stone surrogate and he was just kind of
like the every man character that was
coming in but the story is not
necessarily I don't know if I don't want
to say it's not necessarily about him
but he's kind of like the Observer or
he's just kind of like in every man
that's inserted into this larger
conflict and like kind of showing how it
affects them but I feel like the kind of
the
meat of the story is more about the
conflict like the moral conflicts
between you know Tom behringer's
character Barnes and Willem dafoe's
character you know what I mean like
Elias where if you notice because I
remember that you said
during that one uh scene where they
first it might be the first time they
show Willem Dafoe like uh Elias where
he's walking with his gun over like that
yeah and he said well they wouldn't
carry their gun like that well and I was
thinking to myself the reason that they
had him do it it's symbolic he's
supposed to be like a Jesus Christ type
analog
um so because I think even one of the
other characters calls him Jesus Christ
at one point so it was supposed yeah
like or like a water Walker yeah um you
know [ __ ] like that so I had interpreted
that character even back in the day as
as part as being gay basically he might
have been like I thought that that's
kind of like that they they aren't overt
about it yeah but they were definitely
trying to do like a Christ figure thing
yeah we you know um I was in the don't
ask don't tell era you could have gays
they just couldn't be openly gay yeah it
was a professional kind of
situation where they didn't want
any they didn't they wanted everybody
had to be uniform everybody had to be
the same and it made it makes a lot of
sense if you're in a combat unit there
can't be any relationships between these
dudes they have to be equally Expendable
okay uh some dudes you have to leave
behind to die you know uh some it's just
the nature of infantry combat so you
don't want any kind and you also you
definitely don't want any promotions
happening based upon who's sleeping with
who so everybody has to be equal equally
expendable
equally kind of like uh well that's just
equally Expendable there can't be any
really relationships
um but the problem is is that you all
end up kind of being Brothers anyway so
you can't really avoid it
um dudes it's they've seen a lot of good
movies you know like even um
what was the uh what was the one with uh
Stanley Kubrick uh Full Metal Jacket
Full Metal Jacket yeah yeah eight ball
gets [ __ ] shot by the sniper and
[ __ ] animal mother it goes ape [ __ ]
so it's no I'm not leaving him out there
it [ __ ] runs out there with this
[ __ ] 60s shooting other sniper try to
save him never uh [ __ ] like that would
happen you know what I mean that's
that's not what you do you have to let
the dude go and I think animal mother
got shot no he didn't get shot he made
it through there but uh anyway in real
life you're running into the Kill Zone
you'd be killed you know in the movies
you can make it
if you run into a [ __ ] kill zone
being overwatched by snipers especially
if there's interlocking fields of fire
in there you're a [ __ ] goner that's
why it is a Kill Zone it's all
pre-planned it's the whole thing's a
[ __ ] trap
so but
I don't know it's it's still it's still
a good movie every movie that I've
mentioned is good I want to see
Hamburger Hill again Khan avatan says 87
that's 87. okay so it's a little bit
earlier than I thought it was which one
hamburger help I thought it came out
like two or three years after this one
but I guess it was the next year con
says that that movie [ __ ] changed his
life that that was like his first real
realistic war movie and we watched it
when we were in the Army and we were
blown away we're like yeah that's it and
dudes that were in Vietnam were saying
yeah that's it right there that's that's
exactly the way it was pretty much that
that was accurate
um the other ones people liked them but
they they were Hollywood you know they
were stories
but Hamburger Hill seemed real
to us and we were and we did it for a
living you know soldering and some guys
were actually there I just want to see
it again it's been so long
this one I kind of feel like like I said
it's um
it does have things to say I guess about
the horrors of war and morality and
stuff but like I said it does kind of
keep it more contained I guess like
because I kind of feel like Apocalypse
Now like was kind of coming at it from a
different like a more sprawling thematic
kind of uh like a more epic kind of
thing but this one kind of well because
like which makes sense because it's
based on Oliver Stone's own experiences
so he's just like trying to translate
like his own experience that what he
experienced over there like into like a
movie form so you know so I get that but
um yeah Hamburger Hill let's see
Rickshaw says am I in this yeah yeah
in the don't ask don't tell period if I
could we had gay soldiers
um everybody knew who they were or we
thought we knew them all
nobody had a problem with them a lot of
them were a lot of them were popular
they were just like everybody else uh
it's a warrior gays you know Warrior
gays uh some of them dudes like [ __ ]
I ain't gonna name any names because he
like I said he wasn't out but one of
them was a guy to recomplish him with me
he was like a [ __ ] were you looking
at him he looked like a captain of the
football team big [ __ ] funny
cruel uh very professional though
and uh no if you want to go to combat
you wanted to go with him he was he was
[ __ ] good real good
and uh
you know maybe six one
you know
and uh Alpha as [ __ ]
all right not you're not talking about
[ __ ] RuPaul's Drag Race talking more
like [ __ ]
[ __ ] Ernst ROM in the eighth and the
sa you know like those damn crazy
Germans dudes you know what I mean it
was uh
leather daddies basically
um they're in there now um
I thought that Elias was I thought they
were trying to say that they were
inadvertently saying that he was
slightly in the closet that's how I
interpret it and he was a good character
a good character he was he cared about
people tried to do the right thing yeah
it was like I said that was kind of like
the well the cool thing about this movie
is that I love the character of Elias
he's my favorite
um he was kind of like he was a warrior
but he had like compassion he cared
about the men he didn't want to like do
you know evil [ __ ] like just killing
people with the sake of killing people
like he still retained his Humanity
whereas Barnes was like the other side
of that the crazy thing about it was
that Barnes even though he's clearly the
antagonist
uh you know and he's you know cruel and
everything like that but you understand
how he got that way yeah you know what I
mean they kind of explain he's not like
like I like too that they put Kevin
Dillon's character in their bunny who is
clearly just a [ __ ] psychopath yeah
um because he's just a kid and he just
he just does [ __ ] because he thinks it's
funny or like you know he's like a
serial killer yeah whereas Barnes is you
know he does evil [ __ ] but he knows it's
evil well he knows it's evil and he's
trying it's gold directed though he's
trying to get he's and believes in the
war and yeah and he thinks that well
yeah like he's doing it for like a
greater goal and because he's been there
for such a long time and he's seen some
[ __ ] you can understand like how he
ended up in that situation yeah there's
a there's a scene where a character runs
in on him after they made enemy contact
dude got his [ __ ] arms blown off and
[ __ ]
Barnes he sees Barnes in a [ __ ]
moment of weakness that Barnes is unsure
about what to do he's probably freaking
out or that I kind of feel like that was
him being like he actually does still
have emotions he doesn't still have
Humanity in there but he has to hide it
in front of everybody yeah so that's
like the only time that you ever see
that mask slip yeah you know what I mean
so he does care but he just he's not
allowed can't anymore because it's like
he's been there so long and he's seen so
much bad [ __ ] yeah at the end they said
that we were children of two fathers
Barnes and Elias right and they're
talking about the dualism the duality of
man that
Barnes and Elias were the same guy
basically different sides of that same
guy though the
two sides of the same coin two different
two different types of warrior virtues
um
both of them kind of victims of the
circumstances and
in the men because the the in the story
The platoon gets divided into two
factions with [ __ ] like that happened
yeah it happened a lot okay
combat platoons and units are basically
tribes or gags and the gangs can kind of
[ __ ] fracture
along disagreements just like what's
shown here and then you have a warring
faction inside a fighting unit
usually what would happen is as if CID
found out which is kind of like our
version of the FBI or if the commanders
found out they'd report it and they just
get rid of all the chain of command and
transfer everybody and then send them
all to different units and make up a new
unit a hodgepodge out of another out of
all a bunch of other ones so they would
erase it that way by separating them all
it happened quite a bit
and a lot of times
whatever the case was and it was usually
[ __ ] like this murders
sometimes guys were murdering each other
inside the unit
a lot of times they buried it they
didn't want the well that happens in
this movie too yeah you want the
negative press it's just dudes
they've been killing people and they
forever and they have a limited lifespan
anyway they're semi-expendable who
really cares if they murder each other
they don't the Army doesn't really care
especially if it's in such a bad Jam
like Vietnam
so they just kind of erase it like it
didn't happen well because they probably
think oh well it's like what difference
does it make whether they get shot by
one of their own guys or whether like a
VC shot exactly they all have a limited
lifespan right you know so it's like
what it doesn't matter it actually kills
them they just try to do you [ __ ] up
but it's true right you know it's their
job that was you know you're it is not
it was the army that we came up in was
not the army of today very different it
was an Army that was more focused on
winning and the only way you win from
the point of view of a [ __ ] infantry
so just to liquidate enemy personnel and
enemy Personnel could be civilians too
you know because really the object in a
traditional Army is to fight your way
around the enemy Army to get at those
civilians
because they're working in factories and
doing things that are supporting their
War Machine
that's how we beat Germany we just
bombed away they were asleep the Little
Women and Children should burn down
whole cities
you didn't care about the [ __ ] German
Army just targeted the civilians
but yeah I mean the scene where
um I mean the scene towards that like I
said spoiler alert this came out in 1986
and I kind of feel like a lot of people
have seen this but
um you know the scene where Barnes like
shoots
Elias like at the end is I think
honestly I think is probably like the
best scene in this movie though it's a
huge bummer because Elias is my favorite
character and he lives but for well for
a little while
but I mean just and the way it's shot is
like so good like there's the way they
kind of like confront each other and
then it's almost like
Elias is kind of like looking at him and
he kind of like Smiles at him almost
like I mean the dude's pointing a gun at
him he's gotta know like he's probably
gonna shoot him but maybe he thinks that
he's not gonna and no he doesn't he
doesn't think he's identified yet maybe
it's me it's me it's me but then it
turns out oh [ __ ] yeah because then that
smile like kind of goes because you and
they don't even show his mouth he just
shows his eyes but you can tell that
he's like not smiling anymore like uh-oh
you know what I mean he's like yeah he's
like yeah I know it's you and then like
he [ __ ] kills him anyway but uh yeah
that was like that's watched out
um Zach said didn't this win the Oscar
for best editing too yes it did uh this
one for Oscars won best picture Best
Director best editing and I think best
sound editing it was nominated for four
more but it didn't win the other ones uh
and then Zach said can we talk about how
legit hot Defoe was back in the day too
I was thinking that when I was watching
this movie I was like Wow Willem Dafoe
he's kind of one of those dudes that's
like kind of weird looking but also like
kind of sexy he's real skinny and wiry
but he's got good death definition
[ __ ] bump and win straw he
looked really good in this well and the
thing too about this movie is that I
mean obviously they ran all the actors
like through basically a basic training
like a boot camp type situation they had
Not only was Oliver Stone actually in
Vietnam but they had uh a guy that was
in Vietnam like an older guy who's been
in like [ __ ] tons of movies I can't
remember what his name is but he had a
small part in the movie as well in
Hamburger Hill they actually ran those
guys through basic training yeah they
were actually like real infantry when
they got out of their trade
and I remember that their their firearms
uh their firearms drills the way they
handled firearms and everything and I
mean we we remember going man that's
spot on there did it correctly you know
everything they did was correctly like
it's called like the manual of arms
they're they had real training I want to
see that movie again
yeah they're talking about uh wait I saw
something else I wanted to answer and
that's like [ __ ] now I can't find it
God damn it
[Laughter]
but yeah Zach was talking about the
cinematography in this yeah which is
which is also very good it's like
everything about this I just I just
legit forgot like how good a war movie
this was
you know what I mean and I mean it's
basically I think this is one of only I
don't know about nowadays but this is
maybe one of only two you know Vietnam
movies that won Oscars the deer hunter
was the other one yeah and I haven't
seen that for a long time but I remember
really liking the deer hunter that had
uh Christopher Walken yeah but I haven't
seen that in forever but I remember
really liking that as well I don't
remember that I thought that there
wasn't a whole lot of Vietnam in it
it was more like it was more about like
the after effects like like what
happened to the people that came back
whereas this one is very much like
somebody that is very like idealistic
yeah I don't know if I'd even say ID
well I guess I guess yeah I'd say
idealistic like because Charlie Sheen's
character he basically comes there
because he's like it's implied that he's
kind of like maybe of a higher slightly
higher socioeconomic status than most of
the other grunts like he actually was
gonna go to college but then he didn't
like so he could go over there because
he's like oh my dad and my granddad you
know they fought on Wars too and I just
kind of wanted to like come over and
like help and serve my country and
everything like that
um and then he kind of over the course
like gets sort of like disillusioned
with that kind of thing
but
um so I don't know I I just kind of feel
like
like I said that kind of mirrored Oliver
Stone's own uh experiences who also his
father and grandfather had served prior
and you know he was
maybe uh volunteered like I said which a
lot of people didn't unfortunately but
he did actually volunteer to uh I think
I think one of the best elements of the
movie is it kind of shows step by step
how things like massacres would happen
and there was yeah because that yeah it
shows how how that happens and it was
based on I think it was called the My
Lai Massacre Miele Eli Massacre yeah
that's what it that's exactly what it
was based on very famous what made
Vietnam bad is that uh you couldn't
fight the enemy you never saw him you
weren't sure who they were
but then somebody get killed out of your
unit
then you'd call in some Jets and they'd
drop some [ __ ] bombs on a tree line
and then you go in there and [ __ ] you
wouldn't find anybody or maybe you'd
find pieces of a body but you're not
really sure it was never really
resolved there wasn't any payback for
your buddy who got killed
well that would go on for months
sometimes and it would drive these dudes
crazy you know because it they're
getting killed one by one and there's
not much happening other than just
walking around getting shot at every now
and then stepping on something that
blows up and there's like no one there's
no one directly to blame it so you're
frustrated as [ __ ] right you're not
fighting you're walking around getting
killed
so that happens to him one of their
dudes disappears they find him later
[ __ ] tied up and executed one of the
black guys and they get [ __ ] pissed
they they think it must be that Village
so they walk up to it and as they were
walking up to that Village somebody was
running away
Barnes shoots him at about 150 meters
200 meters
single well-abbed shot puts him down
then they jump on that down
Village then you killed our man that we
found him out there and then who was
that running [ __ ] oh man the end the VC
in the NBA had been [ __ ] with us
forever and the villagers are kind of
caught in between two warring factions
right and they they can't really throw
an allegiance or behind anybody the
other side the opposite side will always
punish him so they're always trying to
stay neutral
and they were hiding underground and
stuff because they were afraid of
getting killed well yeah so they
understandably they go out and clear
clear out the [ __ ] Village find all
these people hide and even find weapons
hidden and rice and [ __ ]
and they go these guys are working with
the VC
it probably were but they had to
even if well if that's the thing is like
whether they were they weren't they
don't know you can't really know right
they didn't know so it's like so Barnes
is trying to figure out what to do
and uh the senior head female there
starts screaming at him you know about
why'd you kill the Pigs we're just
Farmers kind of [ __ ] and he's trying to
clear his money he just [ __ ] loses it
he blows his top and [ __ ] kills her
bam right in front of that yeah it's
cold blooded then the husband [ __ ]
freaks out and all the children are
freaking out and the Situation's getting
worse and worse and then the men are
like let's wax them all let's kill them
all you know because they've kind of
built themselves they've kind of worked
themselves up into a frenzy
and then the LT who's a brand new guy
who's supposed he supposedly has the
ability to shut all this [ __ ] down he
can't really do anything around Barnes
he's scared of Barnes Barnes is a
[ __ ] veteran okay well I mean his
kid's a college kid with no real
experience I mean he couldn't stop it
yeah Elias comes in try to stop and a
big fist fight breaks out and the
platoon splits in half
Captain Captain calls the the the LT
and says okay it's an enemy Village get
him out of there evacuate all the
civilians we're going to take him to a
holding Zone burn the [ __ ] place down
and that's what they did but on the back
of that murder Elias says he killed that
woman and called blood [ __ ] you know
and the captain was like okay if I we're
gonna do hearings if I find out that
happened it's gonna be a court martial
now all of a sudden Barnes has motive to
kill Elias
although I will note that Elias was the
only one with the balls to stand up to
Burns everyone else was afraid of him
right like he was not afraid to like
come out and be like what the [ __ ] are
you doing man because it wasn't just
that it wasn't just him killing that
woman in Cold Blood it was then his now
um Barnes didn't do this but like his
faction like including bunny he was a
psycho they took some of the little
girls two of the little girls and they
were gonna rape them like they took them
out in the woods and they were like in
the middle of doing that yeah and that
wasn't really invented for the movie
because that happened during the my life
what they call it melee milai Massacre
it did yeah some one like cutting off
the ears and all that kind of stuff yeah
I think it had been going yeah that was
that like some of the soldiers had like
necklaces made of ears yeah so yeah my
uh my Dad's cousin Harold Lee Ross had
two Noxzema jars filled with them he was
yeah that was very common he was from
the unit I ended up going it was the
first 327 Recon it was also he was in
what was called Tiger Force it was a CIA
front unit you can look it up on
Wikipedia he was in that when he I got
in in the first 327 Recon kind of Legacy
because he was in it
and uh
he had uh two big old shoe boxes filled
with [ __ ] photographs of everybody
that walked through their ambushes
they'd shoot them all up
things that they would capture weapons
and uh Noxzema jars full of ears just
right ears
it was his it was his kill count and um
[ __ ] there must have been 40 of them in
there
bad ass [ __ ] yeah and he was Harold Lee
was uh
he wasn't normal he was [ __ ] psycho I
mean he was a mellow guy but cold real
cold and it was just a job to him you
know but they
he volunteered for it he [ __ ] ran a
platoon or uh no Squad
and um he got sent home him and the
other guy sent home because two squads
started to fight each other in the field
over an ambush
one Squad walked into the Kill Zone of
his Squad and they shot and killed three
or four of those guys and then they
started shooting at each other and
cussing each other over the radio and
the [ __ ] Battalion Commander came
over with [ __ ] helicopters and
Spotlight spotlighted him in the middle
of a combat zone and broke them up they
had killed several on each side and then
they disintegrated the unit and Harold
leave us at home
and he'd been there like longer than two
tours I think
because he was a volunteer
and it was working they were basically
working for the CIA
they were Army but it was a front group
it was weird
but uh that's so
that kind of happens in this movie
because that happened a lot in Vietnam
yeah nothing in this is exaggerated yeah
personal grudges had come out and what
it was is the [ __ ] one of the squads
from the platoon walked through the
Ambush and [ __ ] they told him said
hey you're not supposed to be walking
around at night that was against sop
moving at night was against the rules it
was dark they walked into the [ __ ]
kill zone they shot it up they thought
it was an NBA unit it wasn't it was an
American unit and they knew instantly
because it's red tracers on both sides
American U.S army forces use red tracers
the NVA used green
so it's just red tracers going in both
directions and they didn't care though
you know how dare you walk through you
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] ups you know what I
mean
it's a professional disagreement
well the thing about it and one of the
things Charlie one of the things that
they kind of show in this movie like
even though they're not like you know
it's not super over but the one of the
things that they're talking about in
this movie is that you know you put you
thrust somebody into a situation where
they're seeing like like horror on a
daily basis like this and you can't be
surprised when they just like stop
giving a [ __ ] about anything anymore you
know what I mean which like I said I
kind of feel like that's what happened
with barnes's character yeah you know
he's been there so long that he just
likes awesome [ __ ] he just didn't really
give a [ __ ] he just like went totally
cold and everything yeah kind of odds on
satama have you ever seen Patton I've
never seen it yeah it's a good movie it
is good I haven't seen it in a long time
but I remember it being now remember
the movie's fairly accurate historically
but George C Scott makes that movie I
mean George C Scott makes everybody that
he's in let's be honest yeah the real
patent was not
that
he didn't have that voice he didn't
project that amount of power he you you
can get recordings of um General Patton
talking
uh Patton was a character he was a real
character he was a good General uh real
good
[Music]
um
but I must say that there were the U.S
had a lot of good generals that were
about as good as him just so you don't
hear about him he just made his story
made a good movie because he was a wild
character
so that movie kind of elevated his uh
Legend
you know but no you should see that one
it's good the only problem with Patton
is that the German tanks are actually
American tanks dressed up to look like
German tanks but like if they couldn't
get a hold of Derby [ __ ] that's just
movies they didn't have CG back then
stuff like that doesn't bother me
crazy
well I know it's like I said you're
you're kind of like the equivalent of
like Neil deGrasse Tyson like every time
he goes and sees a sci-fi movie he's
like the stars are wrong for that day
what are you doing you know what I mean
like I get it I mean I get the same
thing like if there's things that I know
a lot about and like I see it in a movie
I'm like oh that's not right or whatever
but I don't know it doesn't bother me
all that much well just what was
different because the movie's a movie it
was different about Patton Not only was
he a very good Battlefield commander and
a lot of his he wrote really good books
I read Wars I knew it it's a really good
book
um it's very short read and real fun
it's his commentary on fighting the
Germans
and he brought up a lot of weird [ __ ]
that he didn't know what it was but
later it was answered he found some kind
of launch platform out in France and he
described it was a big old long rail it
made of concrete on the ground and a
bunch of [ __ ] concrete structures all
around it he couldn't figure out what it
was and he died before he ever
had a chance to figure out what it was
he got killed at an automobile accident
um
it was the launch rail for the Sanger
antipodal bomber which was a sub-orbital
nuclear bomber the Germans were building
to bomb New York we could go all the way
around the world it's like a space
shuttle
but they invaded we invaded uh
France and took it from them before they
got it finished
but he saw that thing he couldn't figure
out what it was he was seeing it was
some kind of launching date like a
monorail
because it was several miles long anyway
um
it it's a good movie one of the things
another thing that made him him
different is that he was uh very much a
believer in the Paranormal very much uh
he had evidently paranormal experiences
and believed in reincarnation
he believed he'd been reincarnated that
he had served with David
during David's Invasion to what [ __ ]
India what was it uh
Alexander
Alexander the Great he said he's served
under Alexander the Great
Michael says uh platoon made the Vets
finally talk about Vietnam again before
that it was very taboo yeah and I kind
of feel like it took uh Oliver Stone a
long time to get this movie made even
though like I said he wrote the original
screenplay you know or the original
version of it back in 1968. I don't know
I see it rainbow no
um what I was gonna say yeah uh you know
before I interrupt before you
interrupted
uh was it took him a lot because
um they were like well Rambo's not
exactly a Vietnam movie in that sense
you know what I mean yeah but they
thought well there's already been the
deer hunter there's already been
Apocalypse Now and those are Classics so
why do you think you can make another
Vietnam movie that's better than those
um and also I kind of feel like they
didn't really want to make a Vietnam
movie because Vietnam wasn't a very
popular war especially like it's going
back to the 1980s so it took a really
long time I think Dino DiLaurentis
actually uh helped him get it made uh
and Michael said it was realistic
according to the vets and then there uh
John Smith is talking about heaven and
earth is Stone's underrated Vietnam
movie yeah that was like um that was the
third one he made because he made this
one and then he made born on the fourth
of July with Tom Cruise which is
actually like pretty good I remember
seeing that too I don't remember if I
ever saw heaven and earth though that
came out in 1993 and I have heard that
that was good but that was like his
Vietnam Trilogy I guess but I did see
the first two I don't think I saw the
third one though so I'm gonna have to
like see that one
and then Michael's also pointing out
that John Cusack turned down the Charlie
Sheen roll yeah I think a couple people
did I'm not [ __ ] on Charlie Sheen
it's just that he's fine in this
um but honestly I think maybe John
Cusack might have been better
Charlie Sheen is just Charlie Sheen he's
an okay actor he's not a great actor
um I thought he was okay and I think
he's okay in it I thought he represented
the character pretty well yeah making
them all kind of an All-American yeah I
couldn't could have went to college but
said [ __ ] College
yeah go to the Army I kind of now I did
it well now I'm kind of interested to
see what what John Cusack would I can
see why he turned it down a lot of
actors did uh turn that part down but
I kind of feel like John Cusack has more
of like a
he has more of like a depth to him than
Charlie Sheen had yeah like just from an
acting standpoint I don't know either of
them as real people obviously and Oliver
Stone
he's using this character as his
surrogate joining the Infantry back when
nobody was joining the after you you
were just they were drafting everybody
everybody's running from it
is when I when I learned that Oliver
Stone had actually volunteered for that
[ __ ] yeah he volunteered yeah the
condition of the U.S army and that in
one of very few people that did the
condition and quality of the U.S Army in
that era was [ __ ] horrible terrible
that wasn't an army you wanted to go to
war go to war with
just troop quality was [ __ ] wrong
about him training was just [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and the missions that they were putting
you on were [ __ ] way over your head
you know what I mean you just
Richard Brown said wasn't Richard
Ramirez's Uncle a Vietnam vet who used
to tell him horror stories from his time
in Vietnam yeah that's I do remember
that here's the thing though after
Vietnam there was a representative thank
you Michael thank you very much after
Vietnam there was just an explosion of
[ __ ] War Stories most of them fake
you had to really be careful who it was
you were listening to
um just fake [ __ ] that never
happened and any old dude could say he
was there and make up some wild [ __ ] and
it just that didn't happen you know he
was never there that kind of stuff
yeah John Smith said Heaven and Earth is
great it's the true story of a
Vietnamese woman that at one point
fights for the Viet Cong and ends up a
businesswoman in the U.S Midwest oh you
know what maybe I did see that
but it's been a long time that sounds
very familiar
that sounds very familiar yeah I kind of
feel like well
that's the thing like Charlie Sheen
being in this because Martin Sheen was
in Apocalypse Now like Samantha just
pointed out and I was like yeah that's
right so maybe that's why like I said
they there were other actors like up for
that role but I guess it kind of like
this Vietnam Afghanistan Iraq it's the
same [ __ ] over and over again I've said
it on this on this [ __ ] program
before
Americans in general westerners in
general are technophiliacs they believe
that technology can solve any problem
and they're kind of brainwashed to
believe so because CNN did it back in
the 90s they would just show [ __ ] J
dabs [ __ ] guided laser-guided bombs
just hit and pinpoint targets you know
oh we got them how are you Iraq was a
third rate [ __ ] Army it was very
static okay it wasn't and it really
wasn't
about the fight it they they didn't
really want to fight for Saddam
so kind of brainwashed people into
thinking that if you have high-tech
women you win no
not at all if you have Superior
willpower you win
we were down there fighting the the
Vietnamese for years not not knowing why
we were losing the whole place was
[ __ ] undermined with tunnels the
tunnels went all the way into Laos in
Cambodia
the enemy was mostly in Laos in Cambodia
most of the time and and we were in
there [ __ ] with B-52s dropping
[ __ ] billions of dollars of bombs to
just flat in the place and doing all
this [ __ ] with poor and unlimited air
power I don't think it didn't make any
[ __ ] difference no difference
what made difference was those tunnels
and they were built with little tiny
[ __ ] hand shovels and pails like a
little [ __ ] toy pail that you'd buy
at a damn toy store
and a lots of [ __ ] back breaking work
and willpower
they were all Underground
and you know nobody would go in nobody
would go under there to go get them
you know
so there's no way you could win
yeah well you know like I said it's you
know it's a giant cluster giant cluster
and all those people got killed like for
nothing essentially you win Wars by
enduring you just out endure them you
know to where they've spent so much
money and they just they just can't get
anything done you use Terror tactics and
horror tactics and then just endure and
endure and endure and wait and wait and
wait
about 10 years later you'll win they'll
leave that's that's what it's about
that's how you win
Michael says I remember seeing this in
1987 and all these 40 year old dudes
were teary-eyed I'm guessing they were
vets yeah I do kind of feel like I
remember uh that being a thing like that
a lot of vets had seen this and they
thought you know that it really like
resonated with them
um and they're talking about like mango
says JFK is a kraken film one of Stone's
best it is it's not it's it's factually
uh inaccurate for sure but uh as a movie
it's actually quite good I think that
that might be one of the very few films
that I thought Kevin Costner was good in
it Kevin Costner is one of those actors
that's just kind of like there
you know what I mean I don't yeah he
never makes much of an impression he was
generic yeah he he's just very white
bread he's like the world's most white
bread actor yeah very generic um he's
not terrible usually but he's not great
like he's never stands out he doesn't
have he seems like he doesn't have like
a lot of characters he was four though
that's what I mean when you just kind of
needed like a guy yeah we just need a
guy in this role like something to do a
lot of a lot of Joe Blows or are that
guy right so you put him in there but I
did like him in JFK though I did like
him in JFK and like I said I really
really do like that movie even though
like I said a lot of it is like
factually inaccurate but um but it's a
good movie though as a movie like as
long as you don't watch it think it's
like a documentary because it ain't but
it's a good movie though yeah
but I mean we were talking about
um well Oliver Stone because you know
Zach said something about that movie The
Hand yeah awesome movie and honestly
like he had been he was back when he was
making the hand he was still he was
trying to get platoon made or what you
know the the precursor to platoon and he
went in to make the hand because he
thought oh well maybe like I can make
some money like it's a horror movie and
you know they usually make a lot of
money on a low budget but then like it
tanked which is that's horrible which is
unfortunate because it's like it's so
good and it made like such an impression
on me when I saw it when I was a kid
probably because of the you know getting
the hand cut off because like I said
getting Limbs and heads cut off is
always like scary to me
but I always remembered that movie I
remembered that scene where you got the
hand cut off but I had forgotten like
how good that movie was like until we
watched it uh John Smith said yep Jim
Garrison's uh argument about JFK is
pretty much side step and [ __ ] it is
yeah
but yeah that's it is a great movie just
don't watch it like thinking that it's
actually like true or anything because
it's not but it's it's still like a good
movie
um all right
um yeah Mega said yeah it has issues
history wise but a kraken Thriller and
Costner is great in it yeah I think
that's probably I haven't seen a [ __ ]
ton of Kevin Costner's movies but um of
the ones that I've seen that's easily my
favorite role like but he just always
comes across as just very
I know it's gonna sound mean but he
always comes across just very wooden he
comes across as very wooden like he
doesn't really have like a lot of
emotion or passion or he doesn't come
across as like a character he just comes
across as like a guy who do you like I
said just this white bread guy like
you'd meet him and then you'd
immediately like forget what his name is
like he seems like that type of dude
you know some reason women liked him
though at that time that was his charm I
guess because you could just kind of
read into anything that he did you could
add add your own yeah he's like a black
slave
[Laughter]
he's just kind of generic
remember what he did with Whitney
Houston where he's like her bodyguard
yeah it was called the bodyguard
bodyguard yeah it is generic
and he was Jimmy I didn't like that
movie he was generic he was generic in
the post in the postman even though I
like The Postman movie
I actually liked his [ __ ] biggest
flop Water World I liked Water World and
and now I did not like one in Water
World that was the closest he you ever
saw him to have a character it was just
this mean silent dude who could breathe
underwater
maybe he'd be better as a villain yeah
now kind of Watson said he's good in Mr
Brooks that's right I remember him being
good in that although I don't remember a
lot about it but I remember liking that
movie
maybe he should be a bad guy he'd be
more interesting yeah what was the one
wasn't there a movie where he played
Elvis I don't know or he played somebody
that was like an Elvis impersonator
3000 miles to Graceland is that what I'm
thinking of I don't know I didn't ever
seen it Ben says Dances with Wolves was
pretty decent too but he plays a limited
role yeah I remember liking dances
before but I also remember thinking that
he was like the least interesting thing
about it Hugo likes uh uh water world
and um post man if you guys want us to
review those movies you send us
send us the Blu-rays and we'll do it
I'd be careful honestly all I remember
about water world is one how much
everybody shot on it when it came out
and two wasn't Dennis Hopper being
insane in that oh he's [ __ ] crazy
Dennis Hopper being insane like but I
repeat myself like yeah he's like that
at every move water will was a very
expensive post-apocalyptic movie on par
they were trying to reproduce Mad Max
yeah but they were but I guess the polls
had had thawed and there was no land so
everybody's just trying to survive on
the surface of the water and you know
that was like the elevator pitch for
that movie they were just like like Mad
Max but on water and everything with the
water yeah oh my God I love it and uh
that that presented its own problems
right there living on the ocean
and floating atolls uh people trying to
live on [ __ ] abandoned super tankers
trying to grow food out there
uh it was it it had it was a good idea
the tone was a little wrong in places it
was had an uneven tone Hopper and the
[ __ ] bad guys were kind of goofy
yeah they were well that's the thing
they went way over the top and like
Kevin Costner is just kind of like very
very restrained let's call it that had
they kind of restrained that movie and
give it a similar tone to to Mad Max I
think the movie would have worked out a
lot better it was an expensive movie I
think it was one of the most expensive
it was at the time it was one of the
most expensive movies ever made I'm sure
it's been surpassed like by many times
at this point but yeah
Samantha said that's why he played the
corpse in the Big Show
slay in the car
he also said his worst is Robin Hood
yeah I agree Robin Hood was pretty bad
that's yeah that I I really did not it's
hard to make that story good I've never
seen it I mean you can do well you know
what the Disney animated one anime yeah
with the fox the foxes and the Animals I
like that one but uh yeah it's best as
an animated film I mean honestly I don't
to I don't think I've seen like some of
the old ones like didn't the old ones
have like uh what's his ass like uh
Errol Flynn or whatever yeah I think so
yeah um I don't remember if I ever saw
any of those or if I did I was a kid so
maybe those are good but I remember
liking the animated one that came out in
the 70s but yeah live action ones I
don't know if I've ever other than the
the Mel Brooks on Robin Hood Men in
Tights that was like that was pretty
amusing with Carrie always was like a
hamburger uh sure or something like that
sure
okay okay
I'm thinking about food uh yeah I know
Danny Rowling said what's tomorrow's
show topic we're doing two cases of and
these were both suggested to me I didn't
really know a lot about them but they're
both like weird Mass family suicides at
least one of them has like a cult
connotation maybe like it was maybe done
for religious reasons so that's what
we're doing like uh the berari deaths
and what they call the atom house that's
what we're talking about tomorrow so
it's two cases
and let's see what else
um do wander water world is kind of
underrated I honestly wouldn't mind
seeing it again I only saw somebody
loaned it to me like probably in the mid
2000s and I was like ah what the [ __ ]
I'll watch it and I remember
I was like s isn't that bad but it's
like it didn't really hold my attention
like I kept wandering out of the room
and being like man I think I have
laundry to do or some [ __ ] like that you
know what I mean so I don't know but
maybe if I sat down I liked the postman
too okay that was another [ __ ] I don't
think I saw that person was a vanity
project kind of like that too somebody
put a bunch of money into it it had some
problems but um overall it was kind of
fun you know I liked the bad guys better
than the good guys I just well that's
kind of true if most movies to be honest
with you bad guys are always more bad
guys yeah you know that's just the way
it is that's the way fiction Works John
Smith said Costner's Robin Hood with a
mullet and an American accent not giving
a [ __ ] yeah yeah I mean but see that's
the thing would you rather just had him
talk like Kevin Costner or would you
rather have like have to cringe through
the whole movie of him doing like a
British accent
I'm just gonna have him like maybe you
could just put a British actor in there
well see that would be the ideal
solution yeah but that was not the
solution that they chose now [ __ ] it
we're gonna put we're gonna put Mel
Gibson in there
well at least he's at least he's
Australian so it's that's kind of closer
yeah but yeah you don't really want you
don't really want like Robin Hood going
around sound it sounded like he's from
like Dubuque or some [ __ ] like that oh
they're talking about dance with Dancing
With Wolves I actually like Dances with
Wolves I forgot all about that one I
like that one too but I think Kevin
Costner was like the weakest part of it
yeah it's a good movie yeah the Indians
were all cool that's what I mean like
all the other characters were
interesting he was just kind of like
this black hole of yeah just kind of
I'm the boring white guy yeah he's the
boy okay yeah that's you know what would
be funny if like every movie that I'm
sorry Kevin Costner like every movie
that he's in they should just credit him
as boring white guys
generic his character was just to be
generic right yeah yeah
uh Ben says there's a formula in
Hollywood after you have one Smash Hit
movie like Dances with Wolves you're
allowed to make two super expensive
flops Water World and Postman before
they cut you off yeah it does seem like
that that's kind of like that's kind of
the thing
that's no actor that's Kevin Costner
hahaha
and Johnson said Alan Rickman totally
upstaged him too I mean Alan Rickman to
be fair like he always he upstaged
pretty much everybody because
that's true but again he was boring
white guy everybody else was interesting
yeah he just always they had they had to
carry him across the finish line of the
movie
that's what it felt like what it felt
like I do really I do really like that
movie yeah but it kind of like mystifies
me a little bit like how he got to be
like such a big star like because he was
like a big deal like in that time period
he was in like a [ __ ] ton of movies I
don't think it was just his looks and
you know I guess but he just well you
know what it is about him it's that it's
it's not he's not bad looking he's not
nothing like that it's just he doesn't
have any like Charisma that's the that's
how they were casting him yeah if you
asked me it was he was cast he was cast
to be
the every man if you you know somebody
mentioned that [ __ ] Bruce Willis was
generic Bruce Willis was no he's not
here is generic Bruce Willis is not
generic he was nowhere near as generic
as [ __ ] kid Bruce Willis was like
funny like he was like funny and snarky
and sarcastic like he had a personality
like Kevin Costner always seemed like he
didn't really have much of a person out
you know you know what you know what's
coming what [ __ ] Christmas is coming
which means you gotta have to [ __ ]
watch die hard again that's right the
[ __ ] best Christmas movie of all time
I know right yeah well I think last year
we watched die hard and Christmas
Chronicles yeah and I can't remember
what else I probably watched a Christmas
horror story because that's like my one
of my favorite Christmas songs oh and I
watch Black Christmas too because I
think I watched Die Hard 2 isn't that
bad but they progressively got worse
well that usually happens
that happens yeah uh Jason says Tom in
Korea did you have any issues with flora
and fauna such as mosquitoes or weather
oh no the [ __ ] oh of course
mosquitoes would tear you've well and
you talked about how cold it was over
there oh [ __ ] we had a damn [ __ ]
Baseball Spiders [ __ ] the spiders the
[ __ ] asses on them like the size of a
[ __ ] ping-pong ball you'd walk it
through them at night and [ __ ] webs
everywhere
um
[ __ ] monsoon season just [ __ ] we
were out in the field all through the
monsoon season and you'd wake up in
[ __ ] four inches of dab water you're
like how'd this water get in this Hooch
just it just fine it's find its way in
on you uh just now it's [ __ ]
miserable [ __ ] hot
and then hot in the summer and freezing
[ __ ] cold you know 40 degrees below
zero in in the winter oh yeah there's
hell
ucinating from the cold [ __ ]
hypothermia yeah he's hallucinated at
McDonald's hallucinate I'm where are you
going Tom going McDonald's I'm gonna go
get some coffee
I can see it I could see it in my mind
and I could see the light [ __ ]
shining up over the mountain of where
the McDonald's parking lot the golden
arches it wasn't there no
I'm sleepy hello
what was that [ __ ] thing
uh the little [ __ ] uh hash I'm gonna
get your hash brown and some coffee I
said okay man you're [ __ ] with that
went in there whatever hash brown and
coffee there's no hash brown of coffee
sleepy bag yeah Danny Rowling said his
acting skill is on the level of Sherry
Moon Zombie yeah
Bobby is like kind of hot though it's
like you know what I mean at least so
she at least she's got that going for
her she's still talking about Costner
yeah Danny rolly said concerts rolls her
like that of Nickelback song also yeah
he's like the acting equivalent of
Nickelback he's
they cast him in those roles and those
were kind of generic roles of just okay
we just need the every man you know what
I mean and that was the Everyman of that
era that wasn't my generation they're
talking about Boomers yeah those guys
are all gone okay or most of them are
gone Johnson oh I remember this too John
Smith said in the documentary in bed
with Madonna Uh Kevin Costner is
backstage at one of her concerts she's
making fun of him behind his back for
saying her show was neat yeah yeah I
remember that
yeah Madonna's [ __ ] lunatic though
she is I know but I mean she was like
making fun of him at the time that I did
like that was funny because so what a
weird thing to say she marry Warren
Beatty and then Warren Beatty [ __ ]
dumped her
no she was married to Sean Penn back in
the 80s I don't know if she married
Warren Beatty she dated and she put him
in one of her self-made well he was in
Truth or Dare wasn't he that was a long
time ago I don't know if she was doing
like uh uh documentaries about herself
on the side yeah Truth or Dare is that
what it was and he's in that black and
white he's ripping on which is actually
probably pretty good he's ripping on her
from what I remember inside the
documentary he's like man you that
you're [ __ ] crazy
well she's always crazy she's been she's
yeah she's been crazy she's been always
been crazy younger I mean you know what
are you gonna do hey Dave is here I was
like sweet platoon vid and somehow
you're loving on Kevin Costner yeah I
mean we did talk about platoon I promise
but we've been on for like more than an
hour yeah I gotta get down there and
start cooking
yeah unless you unless you want
something else to eat but no burger
sounds good actually good all right that
actually does sound good I'm gonna shut
it down people uh he's gonna shut it
down my [ __ ] job is over here
I [ __ ] this video up long enough
I'm out of here
all right
so be sure to drop by tomorrow evening
same time 6 p.m EST and we're gonna do
our main show which like I said is two
cases that were recommended to me
they're like about Mass family suicides
uh berari deaths and the atom house so
that's what we're going to be talking
about tomorrow night so hopefully you
guys can all make it and hang out with
us and we'll see you guys again tomorrow
good night